Ever wondered what it would be like to talk
to animals?
What would they say?
Well Koko the Gorilla might be able to tell
us.
Hey guys julia here for DNews
Making the rounds on the internet lately has
been a viral video of a gorilla with a message.
Koko the gorilla signs saying she loves man
and loves nature but “man is stupid” she
says to “fix nature”.
While heartfelt, it seems… a little scripted.
I mean, her teacher even admitted to giving
her a script.
But who is this Koko, anyway?
Koko is probably the world’s most famous
gorilla.
She’s a western lowland gorilla who rose
to fame in the 1980s with her amazing ability
to speak using American sign language...and
for her love of kittens.
Since then she’s become a celebrity and
icon for gorilla conservation.
She was born at the San Francisco Zoo on July
4th, 1971.
She’s been working with teacher Dr. Penny
Patterson, then a doctoral student in developmental
psychology at Stanford university, since she
was just a year old.
Within two weeks of working together Koko
had learned the signs for eat and drink.
Since then Koko has spent over 30 years living
in the hills near Santa Cruz as part of the
Gorilla Foundation, started by Dr. Patterson.
She now uses over 1100 signs and even combines
them to make up her own words.
For example, she signed “finger bracelet”
to describe a ring.
But, back to the viral video.
In spite of what she’s signing, Koko probably
doesn’t understand climate change.
Frans de Waal, director of Emory University's
Living Links primate research center, told
the Huffington Post that "Koko's human-coached
message goes well beyond anything that a gorilla
understands or cares about.”
While she may not know much about climate
change, Koko does know a lot about language.Gestures
are something gorillas do naturally, according
to one study published in the journal Animal
Cognition.
And the researchers note that the way apes
use this kind of “language” reflects some
understanding of the audience.
For example, if an ape makes a series of gestures
and its “audience,” (other apes), understand
it, that ape will continue to make the same
gestures.
If the other ape conveys confusion, the first
ape will try other gestures.
This suggests that apes might have some sort
of theory of mind, or the understanding that
others might have different intentions, desires,
or thoughts.
It sounds simple, but only a few animals on
this planet can do it.
So maybe gorillas li Koko have some sense
of what's going on in other’s minds.
But surprisingly most apes fail another test
of animal cognition, the mirror test.
This tests how self-aware animals are by seeing
whether they recognize themselves in a mirror.
Gorillas, while supposedly highly intelligent,
fail the mirror test.
Now, this might not be due to lack of intelligence
- eye contact in the gorilla world is seen
as an act of aggression.
Either way, Koko, who has been raised mostly
with her teacher and around humans who make
eye contact, passes the mirror test...she
even uses a mirror as a tool to groom herself.
She even seems to experience grief and memory.
After the loss of her beloved kitten “All
Ball”, she signed the words “bad, sad,
bad” and “frown, cry, frown”.
It’s a loss she still refers to decades
later.
She made headlines yet again when she heard
of the passing of Robin Williams, who she
once met.
According to a spokeswoman for the Gorilla
foundation, “Koko became very somber, with
her head bowed and her lip quivering.”
She signed “woman” and “crying.”
While she may or may not have remembered meeting
him, it seems she at least was picking up
on her teacher’s sadness.
So, in the end, that viral video might be
a little staged...but come on, what viral
video these days isn’t?
Koko has been a great icon for animal conservation.
And she’s permanently changed the way we
understand animal intelligence.
Her abilities have opened the door to true
cross-species communication.
That’s something you can’t fake.
CTA video
Animal emotions probably aren’t news to
you, especially if you have man’s best friend
curled up on your lap as your watch this video.
Dog owners have been saying it for years:
"Dogs are really just four-legged, furry humans."
And now science backs it up!
To find out more, check out this episode right
here.
If you could communicate to an animal, which
would it be?